as a dark reimagining of Superman's
origin story bright burner doesn't
disappoint
from the requisites Superman references
to nods to produce Sir James Gunn's
other properties here are some small
details from bright burn that you might
have missed spoilers ahead right from
the start the plot elements stolen
straight from Superman are obvious an
alien baby crash lands on a farm in
Kansas later he can fly and have
super-strength and red eyes and heat
vision he even wears a blanket he was
found in as a cape like some versions of
the Man of Steel but if there's a single
visual most associated with Superman it
would almost undoubtedly be the cover to
Action Comics issue 1 the first
appearance of the Man of Steel before
the superhero genre was crystallized as
a concept here was a man in a garish red
and blue suit lifting a car over his
head as terrified onlookers fed away
from him
bright burn pays tribute to the visual
in a surprisingly subtle way after his
uncle never finds out about his violent
tendencies
Brandon begins tormenting the guy on a
dark stretch of road finally Brandon
lifts a car up into the air off-camera
the filmmakers don't make you overly
explicit but it's undeniably a reference
to action comics although in the source
material the occupant in the car
presumably didn't smash his face in half
on the steering wheel there's one major
iconic moment from Superman history that
bright burned subverts Superman saving a
plane
it's an endlessly repeated moment for
the Man of Steel that appears again and
again in nearly every visual adaptation
he's had to date there's a good reason
for that it shows exactly the scale of
problems that Superman is willing and
able to handle a plane hurtling towards
the ground is a job for Superman
[Music]
bribe burn prefers to turn the symbolism
on his head the end of the film sees
Brandon drop his adopted mother to the
ground from high in the sky freed from
the last remnants of his humanity he
turns to see an airplane hurtling
through the air towards him the scene
cuts to a demolished airplane that's
destroyed the rest of the brea household
leaving brandon the only obvious
survivor
but enough about bright burns
relationship to superman the film port
inspiration from plenty of other famous
pop culture works to the start says the
symbol that brandon draws throughout the
film is a lot like symbols used in other
works most clearly it resembles a symbol
used in both berserk and nameless the
former is a famous manga that's known
for gruesome violence are the world the
evil and the demonic presence summoned
by a symbol called the brand of
sacrifice it's a close match for the
symbol that Brandon draws the symbol
also makes an appearance in Chris
Burnham and Grant Morrison's comic book
nameless where it represents the
insanity of an other-dimensional God
in fact the symbol in nameless is nearly
a carbon copy of Brandon's symbol
regardless of where the filmmakers draw
their inspiration it's clearly meant to
signify otherworldly evil and
meaningless violence even if you caught
all the above references you still might
have missed some of the small details
relating directly to the film the
starters did you notice Brandon's
wardrobe changing early on his spaceship
pulses with red light which seems to
activate his more homicidal urges after
that's his wardrobe gains more splashes
of red the more evil he becomes what
starts with a red hood on a gray
sweatshirt eventually leads to an almost
entirely red soccer shirt he quite
literally goes from wearing shades of
grey as someone who can still be
redeemed to matching the blood he spills
on the collar he wears it's arguably
most obvious in the scene when he
attacks Erika in the diner he sends a
shot of glass into one of her eyes and
when she pulls it out she can only see
through a red tint Brandon stays either
on the red side of her vision or right
in the middle for nearly the entire
scene showcasing his transition from
nice alien kid to murdery alien kid
while we're on the subject Erika's
suffering doesn't end with the attack in
the diner as the audience and Brandon's
mother Tori find out later in the film
the police can't find Erika's body for a
reason Brandon takes her back to the
barn in order to perform a grotesque
dissection presumably to figure out what
makes people work
it's actually a moment in the film that
sets up fairly early in a subtle way on
Brandon's dresser
he has anatomical frog statue that's
been partially opened up it sort of
implies that the alien sociopath has
been thinking about what's inside people
and animals for a lot longer than the
movie explicitly suggests even though
James Gunn didn't direct bright burn his
influence as a producer is clearly felt
even beyond the use of violence and
horror movie trappings a familiar face
makes an appearance in the film as the
credits roll the frequent James Gunn
collaborator Michael Rooker appears as a
YouTube personality named big t
screaming about other fake news is
keeping bright burner secret from the
general populace even though it's just a
small cameo for the guardians of the
galaxy star gun and Rutger have
collaborated on tons of projects
together at this point we wouldn't be
surprised that the two are contractually
obligated to work together
Rooker's cameo isn't the only connective
tissue that pride Byrne has two other
James Gunn movies drawing the big tease
video sermon he brings up other monsters
and urban legends that might be working
with white burn to destroy America
including an aquatic creature and a
woman who strangles men with Grob oh
those evil bright burn style Aquaman and
Wonder Woman maybe but the real Easter
Egg here is that one of those pictures
shows rain Wilson's Crimson Avenger from
Gunn's earlier film super shut up crime
in addition the diner that Brandon
attacks midway through bright burn is
called Davos in super the Crimson
Avengers for your name is Frank Davao
and he works with a short-order cook
sounds like Frank's really moving up in
the world check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite films are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]